jamika is living the dream of many young
girls she is a Kumari which translates
as princess but means much more than
that
a Kumari is the embodiment of a Hindu
goddess
despite her divine status jamika still
has to learn to read and write that
Kumari's go to school is a new
development until recently they had to
stay in the temple so they would not
risk hurting themselves because if a
Kumari sheds blood the deity is said to
leave her body we pray to her not here
of course but during ceremonies at the
temple I myself have knelt down before
her and felt her divine blessing jibba
cos time as a goddess is limited when
she enters puberty she will lose her
holy status all the children want to be
friends with her why because she's a
Kumari her best friend tells us but the
Kumari herself is too shy to tell us
what it feels like to be divine after
some prompting from her teacher she
utters a few words in English
perhaps her mind is on her next
appearance at the temple Sumana spent
many years there as a Kumari but when
she was a child she was not allowed to
attend school sumana received
instruction in the temple she had no
classmates to play with but has fond
memories of those years all the same it
was so quiet and peaceful in the temple
and everyone worshipped me I was
something special
I enjoyed that then I was suddenly
outside again as a completely normal
girl and that was a shock but sometimes
wish I could be a Kumari again Samana
managed to make the transition she is
married and has two sons many Nepalese
men do not want to marry a former Kumari
that is said to bring misfortune that
didn't matter to me all that goddess
stuff never interested me I just fell in
love with Samana and never saw anything
besides a wonderful woman in her Samana
and her husband are active in the Maoist
party which is strong in Nepal they only
have different views when it comes to
religion I don't believe in any gods I'm
an atheist that's also my party's line
that's his opinion but I still believe
in the gods and I pray to them for the
health of my husband and my children
[Music]
she also prayed for an election victory
semana ran for the Maoist party in a
local election but her opponent won
Samanas status as a former goddess
evidently did not give her an advantage
people have decided but I will run again
I stand for women's rights and better
living conditions
that's especially needed here in the
Royal City of bhakta port which was hit
by an earthquake in 2015 it's Saturday
morning G because heading to the temple
with her family on special days
thousands come to her but only a handful
of people are expected today before
receiving them Jimmy Carr has to get
changed something she has done many
times since becoming a Kumari two years
ago the priests came to our house they
rubbed a powder onto her forehead they
said that if it did not make her ill
then she would become a Kumari
the other candidates became ill but gbk
remained healthy she makes her
appearance not as G pica but as a Kumari
she isn't the only Kumari in Nepal
they're around a dozen of them but the
local priests think she is the most
powerful one as she fulfills all of the
32 criteria so perfectly for instance a
Kumari may not have any wounds or scars
her forehead should be high her feet
must have a particular shape and she
must have a beaming face the believers
have brought offerings and are watching
what the Kumari does with them if she
refuses the food poverty might threaten
the donor if she trembles this might
mean imprisonment and if she cries this
could mean illness
or even death I believe that my prayer
will be answered but I cannot say what
it is because then it will not be
fulfilled sumana has also come to
receive a blessing and to offer a silent
prayer she is convinced that a Kumari's
blessings are effective when I was a
Kumari in one instance I healed a boy he
was seriously ill I held a flower over
his face and blessed him then he got
better at the end gee because father and
mother also received blessings and asked
the Kumari to be good to their daughter
once she no longer inhabits her body
they hope Deepika will have a bright
future we would like her to become a
doctor so she can continue to heal
people we will do everything we can to
ensure she gets a good education
if jebecca manages not to hurt herself
while playing she will remain a Kumari
for the next six or seven years after
that she will face a challenge perhaps
greater than any she will have faced as
a goddess she will have to fight for her
place in the normal world